[موسيقى]
ونحييكم من جديد في لبنان لا يختلف اثنان
على ان قطاع التعليم بدا يعاني كبقيه
القطاعات الاخرى بسبب الازمات الاقتصاديه
والسياسيه التي تشهدها البلاد فاستمرار
اضرابات المعلمين وما صاحبها من منع
للطلاب السوريين من الدراسه في فتره ما
بعد الظهر اسوه بالطلاب اللبنانيين غير
القادرين على متابعه الدراستهم بسبب
الاضرابات هو ما دفعه وزاره التربيه الى
اصدار قرار يقضي في وقف التدريس للاطفال
غير اللبنانيين في المدارس الحكوميه الى
حين تواصل الى حل مساله اضراب المعلمين
خصوصا وانا المدرسين المتعاقدين في
التعليم الرسمي يحتاجوا على سوء اوضاعهم
المهنيه التي يرونها متدهوره وايضا على
معادلات التحفيظ التي اصبحت تقدر بخمسه
دولارات فقط التلاميذ السوريون هم اكبر
الضحايا وفق العزيزي من المراقبين والخطوه
التي اعلنت عنها وزاره التعليم اللبنانيه
جاءت ما تكفل المني حين دولينا به تكاليف
دراسه اللاجئين لكن هنا وزاره التربيه في
لبنان ردت وقالت ان قرار وقف تعليم
اللاجئين السوريين لم يكن هدفه الانتقاص
من حقهم بالتعليم ولكن تم اتخاذه السباقه
لردات فعلا قد يلجا اليها اهل الطلاب
اللبنانيون تجاه اللاجئين اذا استمر اضرب
الاسد
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الموضوع او نحاول فهمه على
الاقل مع ضيوفنا من بيروت نسرين شاهين
رئيسه لجنه الفاعله للاساتذه المتعاقدين
فتعليم الاساسي الرسمي اهلا بك ومن بيروت
كذلك عاليه منصور كاتبه سياسيه سوريه اهلا
بكم
همم اسم حالي ان ابدا معك سيد عاليه سيده
عاليه لتبسيط الموضوع يمكن القول بان
اضراب المعلمين اضر
بالتلاميذ
وقفت الدراسه على اثر هذا الاذرعه نتحدث
عن التلاميذ اللبنانيين ولكن على اثر
ايقاف تعليم اللبنانيين اتى قرار من وزاره
التربيه بايقاف كذلك تعليم السوريين ولو
انه تعليمهم لا تكفلوا الدوله اللبنانيه
فاوقفوا عن الدراسه همم يعني حتى يقال
بانه تضرر الاول فخلي الثاني كذلك الضرر
حتى نكون كنا في دائره المتضررين مش احد
احسن من حد هل يستقيم ذلك
يعني هو للاسف الحكومه اللبنانيه اضراب
المعلمين محق هو الاساس هو فشل الحكومه
اللبنانيه والحكومات المتعاقبه على اللي
سبب اللي وصل لبنان لهذا الانهيار اللي هو
عم بيعيشه همم مثل ما ذكرت حضرتك السوريين
بيتعلموا همم الدول المالحه تدفع مقابل
تعليما كانت تدفع مقابل كل طالب سوري
بالمدارس الرسميه اللبنانيه ويقارب 600
دولار فراش دولار لا الحكومه اللبنانيه
لوزاره التربيه هلا الحكومه عم بتقول انه
600 قال له شوي همم اللي صار انه بدل ما
نحل ازمه همم الطلاب اللبنانيين قلنا علي
وعلى اعدائي او علي وعلى الثاني همم هذه
السياسه هي مش اقحام هي سياسه ابتسا-
سيبته همم حسب معرفه انه نجحوا فيها ان
احنا هنبتزل المجتمع ده وليه هنبتزل همم
انه يا بت اعطونا مصاري لان همم زياده لا
نعلم اللبنانيين ايضا ونحل ازمه معلمين
وازمه النقل وازمه همم الازمات الكثير
اللي عم بيعاني منها قطاع التعليم في
لبنان او نحنا ما هنعلم السوريين يعني هن
اا كبش كبش الفداء عميد فوقه ثمان همم فشل
الحكومه اللبنانيه وفشل وزاره التربيه
وحاسه لان هي الاقتصادي همم تحججت الحكومه
وزاره التربيه انه خائفين من ردات فعل
يعني ما بعتقد حتى اهالي اللبناني بده
الولادهم يتعلموا وبدون حل الازمه ومعها
يكون رده الفعل لان لا ما بدنا حدا يتعلم
في النهايه مش هذا الحل مش الحقيقه كل همم
يعني همم مناهج الدراسه ولكن همم سيده
نسرين ضعفت تتحدث عن همم ملف ابتزاز همم
تنتهي جهه الدوله اللبنانيه اكثر بس طبعا
ولا اتمنى الكلامها فسؤال هل تنجح في ذلك
تعتقدين
ااا يسعد مساكي ومساء المشاهدين انا اتمنى
انا اتمنى اللي قالته وضايقتك الكريمه
فعلا انا اشعر كمواطن اللبنانيه بالاسف
انه دولتي فعلت هذا دولتي تبتز جهه
المانحه ويعني عم بتجور على الطلاب
السوريين اللي ما لهم ذنب انا اكيد اليوم
بدي وصل الفكره الثانيه اللي الشعب
اللبناني بشكل عام عم بيحش بحس بغبن صار
كونه عم يتامن دعم للاجئين السوريين من
فراش دولار شهريه من دعم صحي من دعم
بالمدارس ولكن ما بيتحمل هذا الشيء
مسؤوليته الطلاب ابدا اليوم انا لبنانيه
طالب حل للازمه اللاجئين بلبنان مثل ما عم
يتنظم اللجوء بكافه الدول التركيه والدول
العربيه والاردن على سبيل المثال وعد
الدول يتنظم بلبنان ولكن اليوم من المعيب
اشعر كان لبنانيه انه فعلا وزاره التربيه
بالتوافق همم يعني اللي صار حتى الجهات
المنح دفعت اموال 60 مليون دولار بيقيلول
ونحن للاسف بن وزير الماليه وبين رئيس
الحكومي وزير التربيه هيدي الاموال مع عم
توصل لنا فاليوم ليعتمد وزير التربيه ما
بيتعلموا اللبنانيه بالتالي ما بيتعلموا
السوريين فاليوم لا اليوم مش مطلوب انا
واقف التعليم السوريين بدكم تحلوا ازمه
اللاجئين بتحلوها بالسياسي واحنا بنعرف
انه هي بدها حال سياسي
نعم ولكن سيقول بعضهم بانه ليست هناك حلول
يعني طالما اتفقتما على ان هناك
اسم حالي ان اكون محل الطرف
وانقل ما يصرح به الطرف الاخر الطرف الاخر
سيده عاليه يقول بانه لدينا مشكله في
تمويل المدارس اللبنانيه فنحن متخوفون
فعليه من ان تكون هناك رده فعل من عائلات
لبنانيين وبالتالي خلينا نوقف كل المناهج
الدراسه وقفت عليها في لبنان حتى نجد حل
هيدي اللعب الخطيره اللي كل مره بتلعبها
الحكومه اللبنانيه والمسؤولين اللبنانيين
انه بيحطوا الشعبان بوش بعضهم انه نحن عم
نحمي هلا صرنا الطالب السوري من عائله
الطالب اللبناني وهو غير صحيح في مشكل
صحيح في مشكل ولكن لا يتحمل مسؤوليه
الطالب السوري يعني هذه سياسه الابتزاز
بتقوم فيه ما بعرف عصابات بتقوم فيها
افراد بس دول ما فيه تقوم على سياسه
الابتزاز يعني صرنا شايفين اهي اللي باكثر
من باكثر من ملف فقط للتوضيح السوري لا
يحصل على فراش دولار السوري السوري يصله
من الدول المالحه فرشته ولكن بالاتفاق مع
الحكومه اللبنانيه في شيء اسمه سعر الصرف
الانساني هذا هذا دولار اخر بلبنان غير
سايره في البنك
باختصار لمن لا يعرف
لنقول انه الدول المانحه عم تعطي 50 دولار
للفرد السوري في بفتره من فترات ما بعرف
هلا كانت 50,000 ضرب 8000 بيستلم لبناني
اللاجئ السوري ما بيستلم دولار بيده
وبدنا نحكي كمان انه في فرص عمل انخلقت
ومسؤوليه عدم تنظيم الوجود السوري بلبنان
هذه مسؤوليه الحكومات اللبنانيه و تحديدا
مسؤوليه حكومه نجيب ميقاتي عام 2011
اعتبروا زوار ورفض تنظيم اللجوء لو وصلنا
لهذا الشيء اللي احنا وصلنا له اليوم همم
بعد كده صار من الصعب جدا ممكن حال بعض
الاشكالات بس تنظيم بشكل تنظيم مثل ما
شفنا الملف بالاردن مثلا اعتقد صار يعني
بعد مرور اكثر من 11 سنه صار شوي صعبه
هذه الطريقه الدول المالحه وخصوصا هلا ان
هنا معترضين انه خفه الاموال بسبب الحرب
باوكرانيا طيب انه ما فينا نبتز لانه عم
نخلق قنابل موقوته وعم نحط العالم بوش
بعضها وعم نرجع نقول لهم للعالم اه نحنا
عم نحكي لكم عم نحميكم من بعضكم انا ما
بصم في اي همم ام لبنانيه هتروح تتهجم على
طالب سوري طفل سوري بالمدرسه لانه في ازمه
عند عند
الاطار همم
الرسميه بانني همم نظرت في ما قبل قبل
اتخاذ هذا القرار تحدثت عن عدم قدره كدوله
على استيعاب هذا الكم من اللاجئين
السوريين تحدث في ما قبل عن فرض عودتهم
همم الى سوريا وتدرج الموضوع الى ان اتاه
هكذا قرار ليس بامكاني تحمل هذا العبد قد
تقول هذا
سيدتي خلينا نقول في شقان للموضوع خاصه عن
تطرح ومدام عاليه في شيء يعني نقول ان
المجتمع اللبناني كيف يعني قدرته على
استيعاب النازحين السوريين نحنا الي صار
الوجود عندنا مليون ونص نسمه اليوم لا في
ازمه بلد حقيقيه بيظل التواجد اللجوء
السوري وهيدا انا ما بدي ادخل فيه لانه
نحن بالسياسه هيدا حالتين وشغله مهمه ما
فينا نهرب منا ودام عاليه الشعب اللبناني
باكثر وصار فيه حاله عم بيخلق حقه بين
الشعب اللبناني والشعب السوري بارد لبنان
لانه لبنان عم بحس لا عم يوصل للسوري
مخصصات ما عم يوصل الشعب اللبناني ولكن ما
الحق على الشعب السوري الحق على الشعب
السوري الحق على الحكومه اللبنانيه اللي
ما بتدير الازمه
اما كيف بدي انا اصوب الامور انا بحمل
المجتمع الدولي اليوم يا اللي زت الكره من
ملعب وزتها بيننا كعوب اليوم انا المجتمع
الدولي هو اللي بيتحمل ازمه من جنب اقرا
اللي بندخل اوكرانيا او غير هذه السياسات
دول لو بدي اجي انا لسوريا ليش لليوم منحل
الملف اللاجئين السوريين كمان حتفوت بمطرح
ثاني بدي اجي انا حكومه انا عم تستغل
الملف اللاجئين السوريين كمان بيدخل لجهات
المنح لا اسالك كيف اعلن اليوم لما اعلنوا
عن خطه انقاذ للازمه همم كان في رئيس
ميقاتي ولا الرئيس همم
الوزير المعني بالشؤون وزير الشؤون وزير
التربيه وكافه الوزراء ليش لما اليوم اجوا
حكوا عن بدنا نقدم ثلاثه فاصله اثنين
مليار دولار من المنظمات ليه انا عم اقدم
هذا الدعم للوجود السوري
في استغلال من الدوله اللبنانيه الى
الوجود السوري لحتى تسرق لانه حكمنا سوري
ايه يعني سرقوا الشعب اللبناني سرقوا لنا
كل المخدرات البلد ووصلوا هلا يبتزوا علنا
الجهات المياه انا مواطن اللبنانيه بحس ما
عندي ما معك مشكل كاشعب بس بحل بحس عندي
مشكل كمان انا لما شعبنا بابقى قادر يوقف
على رجلين حل الازمه السياسيين ولكن ارفض
استغلال التعليم واحمل الجهات المنح اليوم
بس غير فرصه عبر العربيه اليوم انتم خلقت
هذه الازمه بمنطقتنا اليوم ما فيكم تكونوا
انتم دول عم بتحلوا على صعيد ازمه دوليه
وتجو ما تحاسب وكيف عم بتفوت الاموال على
لبنان كيف حتى لما عم يصرح وزير التربيه
وزير الشؤون وكان في اجتماع طلع قال في
وزير الشؤون خذ السوريين وفله لما قبله
يدفعوا له هيد الصيغه فانا كشعب لبناني
بيرفضه ولكن في هذا المنتظر
يعني حضرتك همم نسرين تحملي المجتمع الدول
المسؤوليه ولكن في نفس الوقت تقولين بان
المجتمع الدولي كذلك يجب ان يتحرك وبان
عليه ضغط هو كذلك وهنا سؤال لك سيد عاليه
همم هل يتحمل المجتمع الدولي ما وصل اليه
الوضع همم سوري داخل لبنان
ووضع التلاميذ انا اليوم موضوعنا عن
التعليم وما المنتظر منهم هل يقدرون على
تقديم حلول اول شيء لا انا بس بدي اكد عن
نقطه انه اكيد لبنان تحمل عبء اكبر بكثير
من طاقته
وبتفهم جدا الحساسيه اللي صارت
والشعور بالغبن الذي يشعر به المواطن
اللبناني اكيد يعني هذا شيء جدا مفهوم انا
مشكلتي مع غياب الشفافيه بالمعلومات لما
الحكومه اللبنانيه بتطلع تحكي بهذا
الاسلوب الابتزاز كل مره من دون ما تطلع
فعلا يوصلها اموال عن كميه الفساد بها
الاموال اللي عم- عم توصل انا متفقه مع مع
استاذه نسرين في المشكه اللي هي انه مش
ينحط شعبان ويش بعضه لما بنطلع كل الوقت
نسيت نصف المعلومه في في لحظه انا كنت
باسال بخصوص التعليم تحديدا انه همم لعبه
ماسكين بتطلعها بالسوريين بالمدارس
الرسميه
مسؤول بالحكومه اللبنانيه انه نحن اذا ما
بتيجي دول مانحه بتدفع على الصوره المدارس
الاسلاميه
موجع فعلا اشكركم على الفضور السلام عليكم